I think you know as we just heard you
know there was really only one verdict
we have here you know the evidence on
this was overwhelming you know it shows
that you know not only do we have the
front that capability to prove these
cases we've got a will to prosecute
anybody who's going to see even
attempting to bomb and your conduct any
types of attacks here in the United
States and I think just as importantly
we have the technologies and the will to
prevent these things going in the future
sir talk to me about the technologies
what are they what sets them apart from
some technologies that may be used in
other parts of the world well I think
the United States is a foremost leader
and the tech duck development of these
technologies that can detect explosives
and these these events before they occur
we've got the law enforcement capability
and the will to deploy technologies such
as explosive trace detection bomb dogs
all sorts of devices that can be put
into place to prevent incidents like the
Boston Marathon bombing and we've
demonstrated that in the past we've got
a very strong security apparatus here in
the United States that can be applied to
prevent situations like this in the
future mr. Laskowski do people folks who
were attending a marathon or some other
public event do they give up something
do they give up some of their liberties
in the sake of being safe as
commissioners safer alluded to you know
what we all do and I think it's a price
that we're willing to give up for a
safer society it's not a question of
giving up safety I think it's a question
of people recognizing the fact that the
world is changing and we have to be a
part of that change in terms of a very
proactive approach people are a part of
the security apparatus this is not just
the law enforcement or security
apparatus responsibility every
individual has a responsibility to
report things that are anomalous the
things that they think need to be report
to authorities for following up you know
now we're talking about terrorism but
we've had the same responsibility in
high-crime areas or any place where we
live that we want to make sure we can we
can raise our children and enjoy the
freedoms we have this I don't see it as
a giving we're not giving anything up I
think this is really becoming more
participating in the process mr.
Laskowski what type of reset does this
mean for the Department of Homeland
Security when you have an incident like
this it happened in Boston but there
our ripple of effects across the entire
United States so it does show that you
know we are vulnerable right and that's
part of being in a free society we have
we can't lock everything down and we're
not going to watch every single person
and people are going to get under the
radar and that's what's going to happen
with lone wolf type of attacks such as
this that's the nature of these types of
attacks and why they're potentially
vulnerable and threatening to us so it's
not a reset as much as this is a
demonstration of what these types of
attacks are can be for the future but
the good news is again we have the
capabilities and technologies that we
can deploy to prevent them we're never
going to prevent every single one of
them that's just the unfortunate aspect
of how these attacks can occur but we
can reduce the impact of them we can
lessen the severity we can do things
that are going to prevent future
instance legible sir aside from the
technology what does the department of
homeland security have at its disposal
to keep Americans safe at an event of
this magnitude well this is a layered
approach right this has got to be a
system of technologies and people and
processes it's just not one pantalone
Silver Bullet approach so it's
information sharing it's making sure
that the public gets information back to
the authorities of people that they
think might be suspects in something
like this it's making FIFA again people
being part of the equation to identify
things are out of place as we saw the
time square bombing that prevented a
significant tragedy in Time Square
several years ago and then working with
local law enforcement the department
homeland security has a number of
programs that they're putting out to
local law enforcement not just on bomb
detection but on looking at identifying
home homegrown violent extremists
there's a whole societal aspect of this
to ensure that we can identify people
who haven't acted yet and maybe still
pretty far from active but yet are
showing behaviors that they are being
maybe more violent tendencies and
extremist tendencies and they have to be
reported back mr. Laskowski you
mentioned information sharing I would
imagine across the entire spectrum the
federal state and municipal level how
key is that it's critical I mean
everything is local there's no such
thing as just a national infrastructure
for information sharing because at the
end of the day these events occur on the
street and a local
locality someplace whether they be
Boston New York or some suburban
location out in the Midwest so the local
law enforcement apparatus needs to have
the information that the national level
it's critical that information gets
pushed down to the operators but the
people are actually on the street that
can do something about it equally as
important that information to be shared
up to chain because information that
might be identified as a fractional
piece of information that can we fill in
a bigger piece of a puzzle that has to
be shared back up and that's what's
going to be observed on the street tube
by local law enforcement and security so
it's got to be bi-directional it can't
be singularly just information sharing
from the national level dem come be
piped up and then it's got to be put
into a bigger picture to understand what
that information means the good news is
we have those capabilities